it's an all-out brawl from Florida to
Washington and that is exactly what the
framers of our country intended we will
analyze the high-stakes power struggles
for the Senate for the house for the
state houses for the White House then
young people stopped having sex for
young people and Google employees try to
overthrow capitalism
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
power struggles galore there are power
struggles going on right now all around
the country we've got power struggles
obviously in Florida but we've got it
all the way up to the White House and
even between the White House and the the
deep state the bureaucracy the DOJ the
FBI looks like President Trump is going
to answer questions from Robert Mulder
that could happen as early as this week
NBC News is reporting before we get into
what that means what that means for the
Trump presidency and for the state of
politics let's make a little money with
candid oak and it is such a good way to
do it because let me tell a snipe I was
giving a speech on how to be a man when
you look like a Maddow and look not
everybody is going to look like the Hulk
and not everybody but what you can do
something that matters so much is your
smile if you don't have nice straight
teeth fix them it's so easy in the old
days you used to have to wear a ton of
metal and headgear and get beaten up in
school now you don't need that now you
can just use candid Canada's helping
people gain confidence through
accessible and affordable orthodontic
care makes the process of straightening
your teeth convenient and easy by having
the customer take the process into their
own hands and even though the customers
taking the process into your own hands
the candidates network of highly trained
orthodontists review each and every case
and directs the entire aligner plan a
straighter and brighter teeth in an
average of six months this costs less
than a 65 percent less than braces
braces you know used to be very
expensive plus they're just so
inconvenient and they don't look really
good candid makes it so easy no office
visits needed everything is done from
your home the first step is you purchase
your modeling kit the modeling kit
retails for 95 bucks but you can save
some money today
then orthodontists review your specific
case they will provide you a 3d preview
of what your treatment will look like
and this will save you literally
thousands of dollars compared to the
other guys you're one step away from
getting whiter straighter teeth take
advantage of candidates risk free
modeling kit guarantee when you use my
dedicated link candid co.com slash you
guessed it co f f/a you'll save 25% on
your modeling kit that's candid co.com /
co f f/a co v fe fe - get 25% off the
price of your already very well priced
modeling kit can
see a nd ID co.com / co FFA co v fe f e
you're gonna need those nice straight
bright teeth when you're engaging in
these all-out brawl bare-knuckle power
struggles that are going on all around
the country the big one is Muller will
get to Florida we'll get to all of that
but the big question is Muller will
president Trump have to have answer
questions in front of Robert Muller will
he blow him off completely will he
answer written questions submit written
questions this has been a battle in a
question that's been going on for months
it seems now we have the answer I
caution you that this is coming in from
NBC News so you know who knows but Fox
is reporting it to a lot of people are
widely reporting that the Trump legal
team right now is finalizing answers to
written questions from the Muller team
Rudy Giuliani has said in recent weeks
Donald Trump's lawyer in this case has
said that Donald Trump will not answer
questions face to face with Robert
Muller we have all been hoping that this
is true why because President Trump has
many wonderful qualities one of those
qualities however is not precision of
language he speaks he speaks actually in
a very persuasive and powerful way he's
obviously a great persuader
he got himself elected president he uses
language in a creative way in an
interesting way in a way that works for
politics
but legally it could have gotten him
into a lot of trouble so what the
Giuliani and the Trump team said was we
are not going to put him face to face
with Robert Muller because then you're
just going to end up with some
obstruction trap I mean don't forget of
all of the investigations that we've
heard with regard to the Michael Flynn
or George papadopolis or Carter page or
this all of the charges brought against
people connected with the Russia
investigation have had nothing to do
with any Russian collusion in the in the
campaign itself Paul Manafort is gonna
go to jail for the rest of his life
because he liked expensive suits and and
because Paul Manafort had shady business
dealings long before the Trump campaign
you've got people who were getting
caught on obstruction or of giving false
statements to the FBI so it's all of
these crimes they only come up when
you're actually talking
to the investigators when you're
actually talking to the FBI so very wise
of the Trump team to fight this and it
right now it looks like they're gonna
win this this will be a huge win for the
White House for two reasons one if
President Trump actually came in and
fired Robert Mulder you know he just
fired Jeff Sessions there was some worry
that by putting in this new guy who's a
loyalist to Trump who's been critical of
the investigation they might fire Muller
right away they might not let him
complete his work that wouldn't look
great I'm not sure that I'm opposed to
it because the investigation has clearly
been politicized there have been a
number of investigators on the Muller
investigation who have been outspokenly
anti-trump obviously the corruption with
Peter struck who texted his girlfriend
Lisa page another FBI agent and said
we're gonna stop Trump from becoming
president
he was on the Muller investigation a lot
of questions we wonder why this is
dragged on so long however Mitch
McConnell cocaine Mitch today is coming
out and saying Muller will finish the
investigation he won't be stopped from
finishing it
so if Muller finishes the investigation
and they don't catch Trump making some
loose statement or in a perjury trap or
in some obstruction trap that's a huge
win for the White House because it
totally deflates this narrative how many
left wingers have you seen walking
around in that stupid t-shirt that says
it's Muller time you get it looks like
it says it's Miller time but it's Muller
time yeah that's how we're gonna
overturn the 2016 presidential election
womp-womp it would be pretty sad for
them if it turns out that President
Trump lets Mulliken pleat his his task
and they don't catch him on any
collusion what that collusion could be
couldn't even tell you what they even
mean by collusion couldn't tell you it's
not a legal term it's not a crime to
collude with the Russians there's no law
against colluding with the Russians but
we'll see what they turn up that could
be as early as this week and then once
they get the questions answered by Trump
I'm not quite sure what else there is
for this investigation to do they've
already nabbed man afford on years old
dealings they were there was some talk
that they were gonna go after Roger
stone although stone hasn't been
indicted yet the longtime political
adviser to Donald Trump longtime GOP
dirty trickster where else are they
gonna go are they just going to keep
going after shady lobbyists and
political operatives because that they
could spend decades and decades doing
that and they still want to do it on
both sides of the aisle
there's shady people who operate in
politics on both sides of the aisle but
I think they've kind of got to stop it
after President Trump gives his answers
there's no bigger fish to talk to than
him so that's the struggle right now I
suppose for the presidency or for the
credibility of the presidency and the
White House at least got a big win on
this if the NBC report is true the most
jarring electoral struggle is down in
Florida is heated up yesterday so we
talked about her Brenda Snipes
she's the election supervisor down there
in Broward County one of the most
corrupt places in the country and she's
been under fire they've been finding
boxes of provisional ballots that just
turned up in the trunk of Democrat Party
activists they've been finding votes
coming the day after the election two
days after the election and she has been
totally under fire she's had mistakes
and corruption going back years and
years now even Chris Cuomo thought that
her corruption was too much here is
Brenda Snipes
attempting to defend herself to give the
Scott campaign the information they
wanted it had to go to court the judge
said you had to turn it over you didn't
turn it over by the deadline that was
given that is cast as a partisan
spat that you're doing that because
you're a Democrat how do you respond to
that well I was talking with a woman
today as she came into our office and
she made some statement about a partisan
statement and she said I know that
you're Republican I said I have been a
Democrat all my life in this position I
have been very focused on party because
I want to treat all of the voters in
Broward County the same and I think if
you ask the voters you'd find that I
have that reputation I don't have a
reason to hold anything back except that
I don't want to give out information
that's incomplete or incorrect at that
particular time so concerns are
allegations that we are not transparent
there's one comment that my staff and we
work very closely together always bring
to my attention is that dr. Snipes you
just take time to walk anybody through
our election warehouse I think that's
very important what what on earth did
Chris Cuomo say that would prompt that
rambling nonsense he said oh yes or the
criticisms against you for being a
partisan hack are they fair so she ends
on saying well we and we let people take
tours and we host tours you and they say
we like your tours dr. Brenda Snipes
what she is a doctor of I have no idea
and did Chris Cuomo to his credit says
well you're not letting the Republicans
take a tour they're asking you for the
results of this election you're not
giving it to them you're not even she
won't even turn over how many people
voted and of course she won't turn it
over because then you can't change the
number when the Democrat loses you're
not it's much harder to change the
number after the fact when the
Republicans already know how many people
voted this is absurd I love her her
defense to she says that she has a great
reputation oh the voters know she has a
great reputation of being nonpartisan
perfectly objective very competent no
she doesn't know you don't the reason
that you're on CNN right now is that you
don't have that reputation your
reputation is a terrible one because
you're either incompetent or corrupt or
more likely incompetent and corrupt
because if she were only corrupt if she
were corrupt and competent then we
wouldn't be having this argument she
would have been able to hide her voter
fraud much more easily and much more
deftly but she hasn't been able to do it
so even Chris Cuomo calls this out it's
just a total farce forget those two now
Chuck Schumer whose side is he gonna
take is he gonna take the side of people
even like left winger Chris Cuomo on CNN
his brother is Andy Cuomo the Democrat
governor of New York this is a left-wing
guy or is he gonna double down and
defend Brenda Snipes and defend all of
the corruption going on in Palm Beach
counties and Broward County and say that
we need to extend the recount well I'll
give you one guess
chuck's remember taken away nelson is is
strong as could be he believes I believe
he's won a majority of the votes and as
long as they're counted he will continue
being senator from Florida
the president Trump and Governor Scott
have just lied they've said there's
fraud when their own Republican
officials in Florida have said there's
no fraud they're trying to shut down the
election because they're afraid of the
consequences if they don't in other
words a nelson victory that's what Bill
believes that's what I believe absol
everything those deadlines you have to
remember were passed after the
presidential election of 2000 because of
the need to report to the Electoral
College every vote should be counted the
votes that were cast on November 7th the
votes that were cast on November 8th the
votes that were cast on November 14th
every votes got to be counted we're
gonna count ballots all the way up until
2020 obviously look you know this I know
this the most dangerous place in America
is the area between Chuck Schumer and a
television camera
he's eating this up his is out there
he's taken his stand for the Democrats
of Florida is trying to push democrat
bill Nelson over the edge even though he
lost the election he's trying to push a
gubernatorial candidate Democrat Andrew
Gilliam over the edge even though he
lost the election but listen to what the
reporter asks a reporter says well do
you think that the deadline should be
extended do you think that we should
meet the deadline or not he says
absolutely not elections you shouldn't
have deadlines we got to count all these
all of these new votes election
shouldn't have deadlines elections by
definition have deadlines that is what
an election is that's why we have an
election day if we if elections didn't
have deadlines they just go around all
the time the way an election works is
that you announce your candidacy you
campaign you try to convince your fellow
citizens and then your citizens go out
and vote one day and then the votes are
counted and then you either win or lose
if you don't need to win or lose if
you've been stay in this Democrat limbo
where you refuse to concede elections
where you unconcealed elections then we
don't have elections anymore then we
just have an all-out bare knuckle brawl
for power and that's what's happening
it's ironic because it turns out that I
was right in the in the Twitter poster
they got me kicked off of Twitter
indefinitely I was right I made the joke
I said don't forget Republicans vote on
Tuesday and if you're a Democrat vote on
Wednesday and they did a number of
people have been making this point on
Twitter Jen Ellis among them said yeah
Michael you were absolutely right they
voted on Wednesday Thursday Friday
they're still voting what day is it
it's November 14th it's a it's a week in
a day after the midterm elections and
Chuck Schumer is saying no no no he's
trying to stop the election
yeah the election was supposed to be
stopped a week and a day ago you you
have to stop the elections at some point
I think next time Chuck Schumer is up
for election next time he's running a
race I think we got to keep those
elections will open just keep him open
how dare you another ballot Mike what if
somebody mailed a ballot a mail-in
ballot and it didn't arrive in time we
gotta count all the votes Chuck then you
can sit in limbo well of shenanigans
ensue absolutely outrageous
Andrew Gilliam now the Democrat
candidate for Florida governor he is now
saying that claims of voter fraud in
Florida undermine democracy he's close
he's close to right eye if he had said
that voter fraud undermines democracy he
would have been correct that is what
undermines democracy pointing it out
does not undermine democracy this
reminds me a little bit of when Pope
Francis said that the exposure of
corruption and abuse among the bishops
was the work of the devil no the
corruption was the work of the devil
that that is the work of the devil the
exposure the bringing things to truth
that's the opposite and so the voter
fraud that is the undermining of
democracy pointing out voter fraud is
defending democracy and you've got a
broad swath of people doing this right
now obviously President Trump he's
always going out there swinging he's
always fighting so he's going on in
saying man but you've got Marco Rubio
doing it as well you've got a whole that
whole range the hardline more populist
conservative and you've got the
you want Beltway friendly conservative
and Marco Rubio and they're pointing it
out because it's simply a fact we know
that there is voter fraud going on there
they are discovering boxes of ballots in
rental cars by private citizens in
trucks that were supposed to take them
off to be counted ballot machines are
mysteriously breaking down they're
trying now to count votes that have
already been recounted there is rampant
fraud and there's been fraud in these
counties for over a decade this is
nothing new this is not some big
surprise conspiracy allegation there
there have been instances of voter fraud
here for a long time in this county
where this woman Brenda Snipes was
conducting the elections so the the only
conspiracy is the conspiracy now to
undermine the election which elected
Republican Ron de santis and Republican
Rick Scott and I hope that Scott and De
Santis fight this tooth and nail because
they're up against some pretty bad
hombres Bill Nelson whatever but Andrew
Gilliam is a crooked guy who will resort
to mudslinging awful politics he would
be a terrible governor he would bring
financial ruin to the state and he's a
crook and he's despicable for using
racial slander racialist slander against
his opponent Ron de santis we cannot let
this guy steal the election and I'm glad
that everybody from the senator from
Florida to the president are keeping the
light on it because what happens in
these cases is everyone's paying
attention on Election Day everybody's
focused in and then Election Day is over
maybe a couple days later they they'll
watch the news and then they tune out
and when they tune out Democrats come in
and they take it now fortunately when
these recounts have happened
historically usually they don't overturn
the election I think we've only had
three elections overturned because of a
recount out of high 20s 27 or 28 in
recent years so that's good but there's
a lot of corruption down in this
particular place so we really have to
watch out about that because elections
can genuinely be very close that is true
but what happened here I don't know
Florida has razor thin margins they also
have a ton of corruption so that's the
power struggle happening down in Florida
there's power struggle in the white
house now too we talked about this
yesterday there was some talk that John
Kelly might be at that
might be at an aid that is now almost
certainly going to be leaving the White
House is Mira Ricard el she is a
national security aide and the reason
that I'm pretty confident that she's
going to be kicked out of her job is
because it's not that I heard it from
CNN it's not that I heard it from NBC I
heard it from the spokeswoman for the
first lady she is apparently picked a
fight with melania trump and the
spokesman for the first lady said quote
it is the position of the office of the
first lady that mirror record L no
longer deserves the honor of serving in
this White House yikes talk about not
understanding politics if you are able
to irritate the president's wife that
much if you don't take special care not
to irritate the president's wife it is a
wonder that you've made it to the upper
echelons of American politics that is
really shocking who is this woman mural
record L is the deputy national security
advisor this is not the first time she's
held a job in the government she's held
a lot of posts in the government she was
previously the special assistant to
President Donald Trump she was before
that in 96 she was a foreign policy
adviser to Bob Dole so she's been in
this game a long time during George W
Bush she was Deputy Assistant Secretary
of Defense held a few roles in the
Defense Department at also fairly high
levels and now she's working directly
under John Bolton okay
I suspect a lot of this has to do with
power struggles between John Bolton and
John Kelly for instance between
different factions of the White House
who keep butting heads however there was
a former colleague of this woman we were
a record L who told The Washington Post
quote she's a very tough woman very
smart
does not suffer fools well and if you
happen to be the fool she will let you
know this can be tough this can be
intimidating
I know people who were like this but
you've got to be able to glad-hand a
little bit if you're at the upper
echelons of DC politics I mean DC part
of what makes it such an unctuous place
is that it's a whole town full of glad
handers who would the second that you
know you turn away they stop smiling and
stab you in the back but if that's the
way that the town works you at least
gotta acclimate
self to it a little bit apparently this
confrontation broke out because this
woman mirror record L got angry about
first lady's staffers having certain
seats on an airplane there are a lot of
conflicting stories coming in but I
suspect that it plays on both levels I
suspect as as is often the case in
politics it plays on the personal level
she personally rubbed some people who
were the wrong way and it plays on the
bigger picture disagreements going on
within the White House between for
instance the chief of staff John Kelly
and her boss John Bolton and ultimately
her boss John John Kelly so those seem
to be the angles it's worth pointing out
though that these factions aren't
totally hardline for instance when Steve
Bannon left the White House former chief
strategist there were people who were
considered loyal to him or who were
considered friendly toward him Steven
Miller among them who stayed in the
White House it's not as though when one
guy leaves that whole faction leaves
some people are better at navigating the
waters than others apparently she was
not very good at navigating it so almost
certainly she will be at but there is a
question over you know now we've got
John Kelly's friend and former assistant
former deputy Kirsten Neil Nielsen who's
the head of Department of Homeland
Security she was being pushed out the
other day now you see this budding heads
of John Bolton's deputy at the timing is
a little coincidental I think that's
probably the bigger play here and I hope
that neither of these guys leave because
they've both seemed to be very good in
their jobs
I followed ambassador Bolton much more
closely and I followed John Kelly and
I'm a huge John Bolton fan but they both
seem to be doing good work there so I
hope that this doesn't bubble over into
a bigger problem in the White House at
the House of Representatives we now have
a new Minority Leader for the Republican
caucus they're sorry to say the minority
leader but that's okay
Kevin McCarthy has just won a vote it
was a closed-door vote to become the GOP
House Minority Leader he was not
unopposed for this vote he went up
against Jim Jordan and Steve Scalise
although
it seems that steve scalise is now
running to be the whip we haven't seen
that vote yet so or that the decision on
who the whip will be the this pitted
kevin mccarthy who was an old-time paul
ryan type loyalist he a little bit more
establishment part of the party against
Jim Jordan who's running the house
freedom caucus and this is a battle that
has gone on for years and years now I'm
really sick of this battle I hope that
they work out their differences the
establishment gets a little more
rock-ribbed
maybe the freedom caucus gets a little
bit more nuance to politics and they
work it out because we need to be
unified and one of the benefits of being
in the minority is that you do get
unified but don't forget Paul Ryan the
reason that he became the Speaker of the
House is because he was basically the
only person who could unite the
establishment Ariens and the house
freedom caucus he was the only guy they
could agree on when John Boehner left he
Paul Ryan seemed very reluctant to take
it now listen people pretend to be
reluctant to take offices all the time
however he was uniquely qualified in
that he had conservative credential
especially on fiscal matters he had that
you know entitlement reform rock-ribbed
fiscal conservative aspect to him but
he'd been in Washington since he was in
the womb I believe and they've been
there since he'd been elected since he
was what 28 or something he'd been there
for about 20 years and he'd been working
in DC much earlier than that so he he
also had that establishment Aryan cred
what happens after he's gone
ken McCarthy fill his shoes in some ways
perhaps McCarthy is a better choice in
that he's less ideologically driven Paul
Ryan was always a policy wonk he was
always a big budget guy he was always
trying to work on ways to fix the debt
and deficits Kevin McCarthy is a little
bit more of a political player so Jim
Jordan lost I'm sure he's upset about
that Steve Scalise by the way he was the
congressman who was nearly killed by
that Bernie bro during the Congressional
baseball game and he made a recovery
thought he might have a shot at the
House leadership if for no reason other
than sympathy but the people who were in
the House of Representatives are not
terribly empathetic people so he'd
not win that vote and now it looks like
he'll be trying to be the whip what's
gonna happen to Jim Jordan what's gonna
happen to the house freedom caucus Corey
Lewandowski the former campaign manager
for Trump who's still apparently pretty
tight with the president says that Jim
Jordan will be the ranking member of the
Judiciary Committee this is very
important because you remember all of
those investigations into Hillary
Clinton the Judiciary Committee is where
those investigations are going to come
from into Donald Trump so it might be
good to have a real bullfighter out
there to to go up a face to face against
Democrats when they're launching the
inevitable 10,000 investigations into
every meal that Donald Trump ever ate
that we're also getting reports in that
President Trump allegedly asked that now
GOP Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy to
make sure that Jim Jordan makes it to
the top of the Judiciary Committee to
become the ranking member now it gets
even more complicated here because Kevin
McCarthy can't put Jim Jordan in that
role that role will be decided by the
steering committee and the steering
committee doesn't like the house freedom
caucus very much so a lot of power
struggling at stake right now hopefully
being in the minority will unite the
Republicans this happened to us this has
happened to us in the past when you're
in the minority you can come together
because you're fighting a common enemy
and the stakes of your differences are
not terribly high so you can unify you
can go up and punch them when you're in
leadership it's a little bit harder
because you've got to answer to your
constituents for things that you're
actually passing so it's a it's a little
bit harder to bring people who nessa
don't necessarily want to side with one
extreme or the other together but
hopefully unites us we need to be united
especially as we look ahead at 2020 this
is one of the reasons why losing the
house in 2018 well frustrating for the
Trump agenda may actually help the
re-election bid in 2021 because it gives
Trump an adversary and - it can get
those those GOP House Republicans into
fighting form there are also power
struggles for the White House it seems
as though put money on it now go to the
betting markets this second pull over
your car call up Vegas Ojai
Governor John Kasich the son of a
mailman if you hadn't heard appears to
be readying himself to run for president
against Donald Trump in 2024 comment we
turn now to John Kasich and then you see
him eating in the morning you ever see I
have never seen he's stuffing pancakes
in his mouth like this and I'm always
telling my boy take small bites very
little tiny bites and yes sir he said
daddy who's that guy on television
that's disgusting oh I'm sorry that was
just a video of John Kasich eating
pancakes which is you know when Donald
Trump made that observation that Kasich
eats in a grotesque way I had never
noticed it before and then you look at
all of these clips and it is true and
this is something I've noticed about
people who are longtime politicians
especially Washington politicians they
eat in a disgusting way I won't name
various politicians that I have dined
with but it this does seem to be the
rule rather than the exception I don't
know what it is it's something about not
it's just the government I guess just
working in a bureaucracy where there's
no stakes there's very little
accountability just kind of makes people
a little more of a slob find people in
the private sector no had a dime a
little more in more of a couth manner
that's neither here nor there what John
Kasich actually said was not eating a
stack of pancakes he tweeted out his
agreement with Emmanuel macron criticism
the French president's criticism of
Donald Trump and he basically laid down
the gauntlet for Trump when he tweeted
his quote at Emmanuel macron is right
patriotism is the exact opposite of
nationalism by saying our interests
first who cares about the others we
erase what a nation holds dearest its
moral values America was founded as the
shining city on a hill United we can
keep it that way
United behind President John Kasich the
son of a mailman the eater of pancakes
he is going to unite us he is the man
for this moment what is he thinking what
on earth is he thinking is it possible
- miss Reid a moment worse than John
Kasich is that possible what or his
advisors telling him he is doing exactly
the opposite of what he should be doing
and he thinks that this is gonna launch
him into the White House I don't think
he'll get a single vote I don't I don't
know that anybody in Ohio is even going
to vote for the guy absolute first of
all it isn't true
what macron said just isn't true
patriotism is not the opposite of
nationalism it might be the case that
the French have this bizarre rationalist
abstracted view of ideas floating
without any connection to corporeal
things to tangible things to
institutions but that isn't how it works
in America not for one second and you
know it's really cute of them to be
critiquing American nationalism when the
United States pays for these security in
the defense of the entire world and when
we turn a blind eye when our trading
partners blithely violate World Trade
Organization treaties it's it's Rimma
it's really cute that's really nice it
must be nice to be Europe by the way
macron would have made his statement in
German if it wasn't for a dimension that
yesterday I'll say it again I'll say it
again tomorrow because it's outrageous I
don't need to sit here and be scolded by
Emmanuel macron this weirdo little
French Prime Minister who married his
schoolteacher who was as old as his
mother I don't need to be lectured by
that man it's fine if he wants to be
nice to us but we don't need to be
lectured by him and we don't need to be
lectured by John Kasich give me a break
Kasich was a basically a fine governor
of Ohio the president Trump has done an
excellent job as president we've gotten
a wonderful conservative agenda through
and John Kasich can take his pancakes
and stuff it we've got a lot more to
talk about we've got to talk about the
power struggles of among Democrats why
the framers would be pleased by all of
this and why Millennials aren't having
any sex sad for them took what a great
man said to quote a great man who as we
now know has had a lot of sex sad before
we do that we've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube by the way you'll
notice that I'm not in my studio you'll
notice I'm in my very fancy hotel room
I've got my you know couch over there
I've got my little coffee pot I'm in a
hotel room because I'm on the road and
I'm going to Michigan State University
tonight this is my latest stop
the Y aft or on the co FFA on campus
tour with young America's Foundation by
the way tomorrow night you can catch me
at the University of Michigan but
tonight I will be at Michigan State so
if you're at Michigan State
if you're near Michigan State come on
out let's hang out man stop I will go
we're going to be talking tonight about
why Millennials are so miserable
this should tie in pretty well with our
next story on why Millennials aren't
having any sex there damn there might
seem to be a connection somewhere there
we will analyze go to daily wire calm
you'll get me you get the end of live
ensure you get the Ben Shapiro show you
test questions in the mailbag that's
coming up tomorrow so get your questions
in but what you really get is a vessel
better than this random water bottle
that I have to drink out of because I
forgot my tumbler on the road I this is
I can't handle the the levels of salt
that we find in the leftist here's
tumbler if so this would melt this would
dissolve into my hand it would probably
burn a hole through my leg so I can't do
it I'm not able to drink all of those
delicious left as tears while I'm on the
road you should get yours don't make my
mistake go to daily wire comm we'll be
right back
[Music]
there are even power struggles going on
among the Democrats I know it's hard to
believe
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez our favorite
little socialist is storming an office
in DC she's going she is now she's been
elected to Congress she's gonna go storm
in office whose office is she stormy it
must be storming Minority Leader
McCarthy's office right it must be story
of Mitch McConnell's office right nope
she's storming Nancy Pelosi's office Wow
so incredibly important to go into your
boss's office dormant walk in pretty
wild that she's doing this because it's
not just that she was protesting outside
of the office they busted their way in
there there were 51 people arrested that
were with Alexandria Cassio Cortes I
guess they couldn't arrest her it would
have it wouldn't have been a good look
for Democrats to arrest their big
fundraising star because she's a lunatic
hello
she was just elected last week and she's
already pulling bizarre stunts like this
now why is she pulling the stunts she's
pulling the stunts because she wants to
stay in the limelight and she wants to
worm her way into leadership how did
Nancy Pelosi respond you got to remember
Nancy Pelosi might not know much but she
knows how to stay in power she's a very
shrewd politician so Pelosi his response
was it to arrest okay zo Cortez no it
was to welcome the protesters she
tweeted out she said or no I think she
just gave this as a statement she
welcomed the protest and she calls on
the police quote to allow them to
continue to organize and participate in
our democracy by the way storming
people's offices is not participating in
our democracy voting is participating in
our democracy setting up an appointment
to meet with your Congressman is
participating in our democracy we have a
right to lobby it's in the Constitution
it's in the First Amendment but you've
got to be civilized about it writing an
op-ed is participating in our democracy
knocking down somebody's door whether
it's Nancy Pelosi's or Tucker Carlson
that's not participating in democracy
that's undermining our democracy what
they're doing though is that they're
trying to out Lefty one another they're
trying to see which one is more
left-wing Alexandria Casio Cortez was
just caught in a major lie because she
said that since she's not yet receiving
a paycheck because she's not starting
her job yet she can't afford an
apartment in Washington DC twenty-eight
years old she can't afford an apartment
in Washington DC for a couple months
before she gets paid I don't know what
choices she's made in her life that she
can't afford paying what what do you
imagine I when friends of mine were
living in DC they were paying nine
hundred bucks a month rent let's say she
gets a fancier apartment 1500 $2,000 a
month rent if she can't afford to have a
little bit of money socked away to get
her through a month or two by the age of
28 when she's managed to get herself
elected to Congress maybe she shouldn't
be elected to Congress but it turns out
that was all a lie and she should have
realized except she doesn't but she
doesn't know anything about the
government she should have realized that
she would have to disclose her finances
which means we would know that she has
according to these disclosures anywhere
from fifteen to fifty thousand dollars
worth of cash and other assets that are
also worth thousands and thousands of
dollars so presumably she would be able
to fork over money and pay for her
apartment for a couple of months before
she received her two hundred and seventy
four thousand dollar salary they're just
trying to out left you one another this
is just a power struggle and while the
framers might not be pleased about crazy
lunatics kicking in doors and occupying
House offices they would be pleased by
the power struggle the whole government
was set up to have this kind of power
struggle between all of these various
branches these various elected officials
between the various parties within the
various parties James Madison put it
very beautifully in Federalist 51 one of
the most important passages about our
government he wrote quote the great
security against a gradual concentration
of the several powers in the same
department consists in giving to those
who administer each department the
necessary constitutional means and
personal motives to resist encroachments
of the others the
for defense must in this as in all other
cases be commensurate to the danger of
attack ambition must be made to
counteract ambition the interest of the
man must be connected with the
constitutional rights of the place it
may be a reflection on human nature that
such devices should be necessary to
control the abuses of government but
what is government itself but the
greatest of all reflections on human
nature if men were angels no government
would be necessary if angels were to
govern men neither external nor internal
controls on government would be
necessary in framing a government which
is to be administrated by men over men
the great difficulty lies in this you
must first enable the government to
control the governed and in the next
place oblige you to control itself
that's where these power struggles are
coming from I think it's fine bring it
on
we must make sure that justice prevails
we must make sure that people aren't
cheating that they aren't committing
acts of fraud but for ambition to
counteract ambition works well for me
that said all of that said the left is
still absolutely out of its mind here
maybe we can close on we won't be able
to close on why Millennials don't have
any sex we'll get to that tomorrow but
you do have to hear this from these left
wingers look we've picked on Alexandria
Cassio Cortes right we've picked on her
because she doesn't know very much and
we're holding her up and it's really
just a straw man
never mind that she is the darling of
the Democrat Party never mind
that she's now an elected congresswoman
never mind any of that we're just
picking on her forget leave her alone
because why because she won't give an
answer on how to pay for the absurd
health care plan that all of the
Democrats are touting here's how she
described it to Jorge Ramos people often
say like how are you gonna pay for it
and I find the question so puzzling
because
how do you pay for something that's more
affordable how do you pay for cheaper
rent how do you pay for it you just pay
for it who are paying more now you just
pay for it you just you know you just
pay they W the way you double tax
receipts to the government is just you
just do it just cuz just you do it okay
so I sort of see how it might be fair
criticism to only focus on okay ok Ortez
because she doesn't know anything she's
probably not very intelligent and she's
certainly not knowledgeable about
anything so that's fine how about we ask
the CEO of the Democratic National
Committee which by the way I didn't know
they had a CEO this is news to me this
that's a role I've never heard of before
but the CEO of the Democratic National
Committee seemed Anandi was asked this
exact same question is her answer any
better going to be a winning issue for
Democrats in 2020 how do you answer the
question of how are you going to pay for
this because there have been studies
credible studies that say it would it
would cost three trillion dollars a year
you would have to double everybody's
taxes or maybe triple everybody's taxes
huh just how do you answer the cost
question so so I don't think we're there
yet I mean I think what we saw with a
Republican this Republican Party is we
saw an irresponsible tax cut and then we
saw an immediate pivot that they did
towards it was in statements by Mitch
McConnell just shortly before the
election but statements that they've
been making all along that they plan to
go after Medicare Social Security
Medicaid next it is this president that
is causing skyrocketing deficits and now
they plan on going after these core
programs so you know your answer is I
don't know you know how we're going to
get there but these are all big
conversations that we need to be engaged
in why are they so bad at filibustering
why is she she's no better than Brenda
Snipes she's no better than the County
Supervisor in Broward County the
election supervisors well well Chris
good question let me talk about
something completely different and then
at least you know seem Ananda has the
integrity to at the end of her non
answer admit that she didn't give an
answer and so she says well and so you
know the question I guess is I don't you
I don't know how we'll get there but
these are big conversations just in case
just in case you thought they were small
conversations I know that's what you
were asking me about you know are these
big or small they're big they're really
big and so and that's why I think that
the airspeed velocity of an unladen
swallow so that's her answer her answer
is we don't know and we're not there yet
this is a beautiful irony this is a
beautiful irony I never again want to
hear from Democrats that Republicans
don't have a health care plan this was
the big criticism the big criticism was
during 2010 2012 2016 they say your
Republicans want to repeal Obamacare
that's all you ever talk about but what
are you gonna replace it with you don't
have a health care plan you where's your
plan you've been campaigning on this
where's your plan and there were various
Republican health care plans there was
good work put out out of a EEI they
suggested some there were some good
plans on the table but fair enough I
understand Republicans had the
opportunity to repeal and replace
Obamacare they failed to do it what's
your plan what's your plan you were
you've been campaigning how many
Democrats campaigned in 2018 on Medicare
for all that actually is a clear-cut
plan it has a price tag it's pretty
clear so the answer should be obvious
how are you gonna pay for it they don't
have a plan they'd well I don't know
because the answer is you would have to
tax Americans to death
you'd have to tax Americans to death in
the name of keeping them alive and and
you would also destroy the major
healthcare system in the world and stop
health care innovation for the entire
globe in the process but you don't have
an answer you don't have an answer
because if you give that answer you'll
never win office for the next 20 years
and I just love it's a wonderful irony
it also highlights the central problem
of health care which is a central
problem of all material things you can't
get something for nothing you can't do
it you can sometimes buy something and
then get nothing like if you read for
instance reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide you'll get a lot of
education you'll get a lot of knowledge
but the pages won't have anything in
but you can't get something for nothing
and that's what Democrats are promising
on health care this is this is why we
all knew that if you like your doctor
you can't keep your doctor so why we all
knew Obamacare would not save money it
would cost a ton of money eventually
Barack Obama admitted that himself he
said well you didn't think that you were
gonna get all that good stuff for free
did you yeah we did cuz you told us that
that also that's why you lost the house
and all the state houses and eventually
the zenit is cuz you lied straight to
our faces and you said we would get all
that good stuff for free and then it
wasn't for free that's their problem
here if Democrats want to be honest
about their health care plan they have
to say that people are going to have to
double at least double their tax
receipts to the government and and just
to begin to pay for it and probably it's
gonna cost even more to say nothing of
surrendering some of their freedom of
choice that we now enjoy in our current
health care system that's a hard pitch I
don't think they're gonna do it so
you're not going to have an honest
answer and and Republicans need to do a
better job at least of articulating what
freedom means freedom means that not
everybody gets the Cadillac plan all the
time for free that we actually won't
even have a Cadillac plan if everybody
gets it for free
the way that you spur innovation which
benefits every single person is by
having various variously priced medical
services and and goods and tools that
are gonna cost more money and they might
cost more the insurance company it might
cost more to individuals they might cost
more to the government but there is a
cost to that you can't get something for
nothing okay tomorrow we'll have to talk
about why young people aren't having sex
it was just it's so much of a downer
topic to end on that I've it's much
better to end on Democrats having
absolutely nothing on health care okay
coming out if you're at Michigan State
tonight if you're at University of
Michigan tomorrow see you there
otherwise I'll see you right back here
tomorrow in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy Board senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018